elon musk and twitter gearing up for a
legal battle after musk terminated his
deal to buy the company twitter
reportedly planning to sue musk to make
sure the deal goes through the
billionaire responding with some meme
warfare tweeting quote they said i
couldn't buy twitter then they wouldn't
disclose bot info now they want to force
me to buy twitter in court now they have
to disclose bot info in court musk also
taunting with this chuck norris meme
declaring it chuck mate
that's awesome i liked musk jesse
i don't know why
twitter
doesn't tell people how many bots there
are how can they get away with doing it
imagine if fox news declared their
ratings and then you know half of them
were robots we wouldn't get away with
that whoa careful if you're treading on
some very
scary grounds
no comment
i just want to take a moment to
recognize how much the lawyers are going
to get paid
this is what you dream about in law
school yep you have the richest man in
the world
suing or getting sued by a billion
dollar company and he's erratic and this
could go on for years the billing just
alone i just wanted i would frame it and
put it in my office and then i'd retire
i heard an interview with elon and he
said while he was answering the question
he was also thinking about propulsion
technology for his jet at the same time
a new algorithm for ai while at the same
time thinking about a new
cobalt add-on to his
electric car battery
now when i'm answering someone's
question i'm trying not to stutter he's
figuring out like massive mathematical
equations so do i have any idea what
he's thinking with this thing i have no
idea what i hope is he's trying to get
the price down
and ends up buying it for less money and
so he stops banning my people and and
rigging elections yeah that isn't that
what it is harold uh in april when he
made the the the proposal or when he
offered to buy it it was 54 a share now
it's like 36 or something like that
isn't that what it is he bought it here
but he wants to buy it here
sounds like it look without the benefit
of discovery we won't we won't know a
whole lot but once we get to discovery
we'll have have a great sense and the
judge will have a strong opinion on this
i think that the question i think
becomes is
um what is the contract we've heard
people talk about it uh we've heard each
side say what was in the contract and
some believed he was in one was in a
material breach one believes they were
not and then two is it binding
uh and delaware courts are going to have
that their credibility is going to be on
the line here too because this is a case
that so many young people are going to
watch the longevity of certainty and
reliability around what happens in those
courts is going to be on trial in many
ways and i for one am going to be
watching i do know twitter stock keeps
dropping the future viability of the
company's at stake if that is the case
and from from musca's standpoint
if he is if it is proven and discovery
shows that these bots they provide
everything because they're saying they
did
he's going to have a pretty hefty bill
to pay well how about this analogy dana
when you buy a house you make an offer
and then you start in with the contracts
and then you bring in the inspector and
when the inspector finds termites then
you say i'm giving you less money or the
deal's off i mean there's termites in
twitter right you can't force the buyer
to buy a termite invested house right so
what are they how can i know that's a
great question for the judge i'll make
just two quick points for conservatives
uh
elon musk is not coming to save you
necessarily right so
be paying attention to the other ways to
deal with this and to the employees of
twitter if elon musk can destroy your
company just by starting rumors that
he's going to buy your company the
company is probably not all that great
to begin with big time judge rule give
me the rule take them into your chambers
who has the upper hand i don't know who
has the upper hand but we've heard for a
long time that twitter has failed to
respond to repeated requests for
information about the number of bots
they say five percent elon musk thinks
it's more than that in addition to that
apparently twitter is taking action that
they shouldn't be taking by firing
people that they needed elon musk's
consent to actually fire
in addition he relied that's elon musk
relied to his detriment on their promise
that there were only five percent of the
bot of of the company was spots
so i'm not i'm i'm not saying that
twitter i'm not thinking they're in a
really strong position so then the
question is people are saying well you
know elon musk can go to jail well i
someone said that on one of the business
channels today they're saying contempt
of court if he doesn't follow the
judge's uh call but then the question is
a bigger issue and that is can they i
know can they be forced to actually make
elon musk buy the company if he doesn't
want to so what's going to happen here
is there's going to be a negotiation
elon musk i think in the end is going to
end up buying it unless he's lost
interest in it and he's going to buy it
for a lot less than what he offered hi
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now